we begin the day here in europe knowing
more today than we did yesterday about
the new omicron coronavirus variant and
this is when a matter of days matters
today the netherlands confirmed that two
people there tested positive for the
omicron variant more than a week ago now
the world first learned of the new
variant just five days ago and it shows
just how little we really know right now
about omicron
well today german chancellor angela
merkel and the man who will replace her
later this week olaf schultz met with
germany's 16 federal leaders to discuss
how the country should move forward in
dealing with the pandemic no decisions
were announced we don't expect those to
come until thursday and that's despite
the spiraling number of new cases and
the new variant that has been detected
here
for more now i'm joined by paula
picholte she's a member of the german
bundestag for the greens and she's also
a physician it's good to have you on the
program i want to start and ask for your
reaction to this report that is coming
out tonight that olaf schultz set to
become the new chancellor reportedly
saying that he would back mandatory
vaccinations for everyone in germany as
early as february
i think we have to acknowledge that
public support for general vaccine
mandates is surging and also many of my
colleagues are now understanding that we
won't prevent a fifth or sixth wave of
covet infections if we don't have
vaccination rates above 90 percent and
it's quite unlikely that we are going to
have vaccination rates above 90
percent without vaccine mandates and
that's why the discussion about vaccine
mandates
is very likely to be held in parliament
quite soon and is that going to be the
new government stance you're not going
to support new lockdowns but you are
going to support requiring everyone to
be vaccinated
i think it very strongly depends on what
you call a lockdown and whatnot we are
discussing very
very
strict contact restrictions especially
for people who are not vaccinated
but yes it's true
we are going to see if there is a
majority in parliament for general
vaccine mandates and i think the
decision about that is going to be made
in the next weeks
you know we have seen
protests in austria for example on news
of the mandate there
do you expect
to see that type of public outcry
if
the new chancellor says yes we are
in favor of requiring everyone to get
their shots
first of all we do already have
anti-covert measure
measure protests all over germany
especially in
the state where i'm from and saxony and
to all those people who say that vaccine
mandates would lead to further
disruption of society
i say
the current measures the need for
prolonged anti-covert measures because
not enough people are vaccinated
those are causing more disruption in
society than any vaccine mandate ever
could
and is there a plan
if the mandates are
put into force
if people resist
and just say no i will not be vaccinated
in civil disobedience if you will is
there a plan on how to enforce
the mandate
i mean this wouldn't be the first
vaccine mandate in history we've had
vaccine mandates before and in fact we
currently do have measles vaccine
mandates for example for health care
workers so it usually works with
monetary fines and of course people are
not going to be direct to vaccination
places but it's very likely that there
are going to be fines however this is
going to be part of the discussion
that is going to be held in parliament
and you know there are already fines for
people who for example don't get their
children vaccinated
against polio
but you still have people who resist um
do do you think that fines in the
pandemic would be any different or would
be any more effective to get people to
change their minds
i do think i mean we currently we do
have fines for parents who don't get
their children vaccinated against
measles
and um we do see that many many parents
in the end do opt for vaccination
because it's just too big a hustle
to
to stay with your decision to to not
vaccinate i think
for many many people this is going to be
a very strong very clear reason to opt
for vaccination
and but of course we are going to talk
about
how how big those fines are going to be
if they have to be paid yearly if
there's other measures that can be taken
for for people who don't uh want to
vaccinate um
but but i think this discussion needs to
be de-held in the next weeks
i think that we do have as a society we
do have to accept the fact that after
multiple virus variants we now have a
voice that requires vaccination rates so
high
that they can't be achieved in germany
without mandates
genji i mean a lot of people hearing you
will agree with you but
the the voters in your constituency
they're in saxony a lot of them don't
agree with what you're saying are you
concerned that if a mandate is enforced
um that could trigger voters to go to
the polls in the next election and to
voice their dissent and it could cost
you your seat in parliament are you
worried about that
i think that uh if at all a secondary
concern i'm much more concerned about
people who are vaccinated
who got vaccinated hearing that this
would mean that they would get freedoms
back that
the situation would become better if
they are vaccinated and now especially
those people
who are the majority even in saxony way
more than 50 percent are vaccinated here
i'm way more concerned that those people
could lose trust in government and
politics as well
and i think
when when it comes to decisions like
vaccine mandates we have to carefully
balance all
those arguments in favor and against
vaccination mandates and especially if i
look at the saxonian society i do think
that vaccine mandates are required
paula
a member of the german parliament with
the greens we appreciate your time and
your insights tonight thank you
thank you